angela bueno ya van más de 1200 líderes
asesinados
1.286 y la ciudad a de 171 este año
realmente es una cifra dramática es una
es amenazas procedentes sicarios de
grupos armados de gente con intereses de
controlar territorios o de hacer
política de trabajo forman ya electoral
ya se produjo una masacre para terminar
el año contra un concejal del partido
conservador y así es yo creo que hay una
situación de violencia descontrolada
está golpeando a muchas comunidades
porque falla o porque sigue fallando el
estado en protegerlos qué se puede hacer
pues la verdad que pues son muchos los
factores no porque en todo caso hay que
señalar que del año 2021 comparado con
el año 2020 hay una disminución en otros
indicadores de asesinato de líderes y de
combatientes que están reincorporándose
pero las políticas son insuficientes
sobre todo porque no están acompañadas
de políticas sociales y porque no hay un
verdadero esfuerzo de desmantelar no
solamente el grupos armados sino los que
están atrás son intereses muy poderosos
de mafias de narcotráfico de gente que
está en el lado de activos que se
incrustaba de los poderes políticos y en
cambio por la orientación de seguridad
se dirige solamente a la cúpula de
grupos armados criminales como lo que
habría que ser un replanteamiento en
este año las comunidades en el país en
muchos sectores están proponiendo un
pacto por la vida están exigiendo un
acatamiento incondicional en las normas
de derecho humanitario que se haya un
cese al fuego de hostilidades en medio
de la campaña electoral que viene y a
esto se ha sumado en muchos sectores
incluso los monseñores de la iglesia
católica
pacífico colombiano se han unido a ese
llamamiento de un pacto humanitario y de
hacer de la vida un compromiso de todos
los que están con responsabilidades y en
campañas políticas en este primer
trimestre